DANCING, SELL -- SELL BRA
TORELY.
>> THAT ONE IN THAT PICTURE
DOESN'T LOOK.
>> YOU WEREN'T GOING TO GO.
NOW YOU WILL?
>> NO, IT'S A DIFFERENT-SHAPED
FACE.
>> I SPENT LIKE AN HOUR ON
SATURDAY INVOLVED IN THIS.
>> MELANIA IS A VERY TALL,
STATUESQUE WOMAN.
AND THE ONE THAT WE SAW, THE
FIRST ONE THAT WE SHOWED, SHE
LOOKS KIND OF SHORT.
NOT THIS ONE.
BUT THAT ONE.
>> WELL.
>> LOOK HOW SHORT SHE LOOKS.
>> COULD BE IN FLATS.
HER HUSBAND IS LIKE 6'7", AND A
STABLE GENIUS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED THE FAKE
NEWS PHOTOSHOPPED PICTURES OF
MELANIA AND SAID IT'S NOT HER BY
MY SIDE.
THEY'RE ONLY GETTING MORE
DERANGED WITH TIME.
A SPOKESWOMAN IS BLASTING THE
SHOW AS SHAMEFUL.
SO JESSE, LET'S SAY IT'S TRUE.
LET'S SAY IT IS A FAKE PHOTO.
WOULDN'T YOU LOVE TO HAVE A FAKE
JESSE TAKE YOUR PLACE?
>> WE HAVE ONE.
>> MAYBE ONE DAY A WEEK.
>> IT'S DAVID SCHWIMMER.
>> I HATE TO SAY THIS.
I AGREE WITH JOY.
CAN WE PUT THE SCREEN BACK UP
THERE?
THERE IS SOMETHING VERY
SUSPICIOUS.
>> OF MELANIA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MOUTH,
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE IN THE
MOUTH AND THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT -- HEAR ME OUT ON THIS.
THERE'S A HEIGHT DIFFERENCE.
I'M KIDDING!
I'M KIDDING.
>> THANK GOODNESS.
>> THE THING --
>> IS THAT CAITLYN JENNER WITH
THE MEMORIAL PARK -- PRESIDENT?
>> YOU DON'T NEED A BODY DOUBLE
IF YOU'RE MELANIA.
IF YOU'RE A MODEL, THERE'S SO
SUCH THING AS A BODY DOUBLE FOR
A MODEL.
IT'S A MODEL.
SHE'D BE MORE FAMOUS AND HAVE A
MUCH BETTER JOB OF BEING A BODY
DOUBLE FOR MEL RANNIA.
-- MELANIA.
REMEMBER THE OTHER CONSPIRACIES?
WE REMEMBER TRUMP WAS GOING HAND
THE REINS OVER TO PENS AND THAT
TRUMP IS A PUPPET OF PUTIN OR IT
WASN'T HIS REAL HAIR?
>> .THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS FROM
KENYA?
[LAUGHTER]
>> I WANTED TO TAKE THAT JOKE
FROM YOU.
>> I'M DONE.
I'VE DONE.
>> THERE WAS ALSO A RUMOR THAT
HE AND HILLARY WERE HAVING A
DALLIANCE DURING THE 2016
CAMPAIGN.
>> DID BILL KNOW?
>> OF COURSE HE KNEW.
>> BILL WAS DOING HIS OWN THING
WHICH WAS ACTUALLY TRUE.
>> BUT KATIE, WHAT IS THE
SUBTEXT HERE?
THAT THE FIRST LADY HAS TEETHED
OUT AND SHE ACTUALLY IS ON
PERMANENT SAFARI, THAT SHE CAN'T
STAND BEING AROUND THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE'S HORRIBLE AND HE
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED?
>> SHE CAN'T CATCH A BREAK.
IF SHE WASN'T DOING ALL THESE
INITIATIVES SHE'S DOING ON HER
OWN AS HER OWN PERSON, BUILDING
HER OWN THING, SHE WOULD BE
ACCUSED OF BEING A STEP FORWARD
WIFE BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T HAVE
A -- STEPFORD WIFE BECAUSE SHE
DIDN'T HAVE A BRAIN.
SHE PROVES HER OWN PERSON.
SHE'S GONE ALL THESE TRIPS, GONE
OVERSEAS.
SHE'S CAPABLE OF TALKING AND
PUSHING THE THINGS SHE WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT AND THEY STILL
CRITICIZE HER.
I THINK IT'S PETTY.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THEY
COULD BE TALKING ABOUT AND I
FIND IT INTERESTING THAT THE
WOMEN WHO ARE ALWAYS SAYING, YOU
KNOW, THE WOMEN WHO DON'T HELP
WOMEN ARE GOING TO HELL.
DECIDE TO ENGAGE IN THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
>> ONE, ISN'T KATIE RIGHT?
LEAVE HER ALONE.
>> YES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TWEETING OUT
AND RAISING IT.
HE DELIGHTS IN THE IDEA THAT
HE'S SOMEHOW --
>> WOULDN'T YOU DO THE SAME?
>> HE'S NOT DEFENDING HIS WIFE.
>> CERTAINLY HE GOES.
>> HE'S DEFENDING HIMSELF
AGAINST THE CHARGE THAT HE HAS A
DOUBLE FOR HIS WIFE BECAUSE AS
YOU SUGGEST, MAYBE HIS WIFE
IS --
>> IT'S AN INSULT TO HER AND
THEIR MARRIAGE.
>> TO ME THIS IS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF CONSPIRACY THEORY
WACKINESS AND A DISTRACTION FROM
THE REALITY.
HOW ABOUT THE BOAT IN WHICH
REPUBLICANS WILL SAY, HEY YOU
CAN YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT WALL, THAT EMERGENCY,
BOGUS.
>> I WAS ACTUALLY.
>> PEOPLE WERE MAKING JOKES
ABOUT THE PICTURE, DIFFERENT
JOKES ABOUT HOW -- HOW HUMORLESS
AND UNFUN THEY LOOK TOGETHER
WITHOUT POINTING OUT THEY WERE
AT A SOMBER EVENT.
THEY WERE THERE -- OF A NATURAL
DISASTER.
BUT I HAVE YET TO BE FAIR.
CONSPIRACIES ARE BAD ON BOTH
SIDES.
AND POLITICAL PLAYER, YOU GET
INTO THE PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
SO YOUR IMMUNITY GOES AWAY
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BELIEVE.
SO RIGHT NOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS A LOWERED IMMUNITY AMONG "THE
VIEW" BECAUSE THEY HATE THIS GUY
SO MUCH THAT THIS HAS TO BE AN
IMPOSTER.
BUT LIKEWISE, WE'VE HAD OUR
SHARE OF THESE KINDS OF -- OF
CONSPIRACIES BECAUSE WE HAD SUCH
DEEP DISLIKE FOR THE OTHER SIDE.
>> QUESTION NEVER DID SEE THE
PRESIDENT'S TRANSCRIPTS.
REMEMBER?
HOW DID HE GET FROM OCCIDENTAL
COLLEGE --
>> IS THAT HIS REAL NAME?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> DOESN'T THINK THE BER
CERTIFICATE IS REAL.
>> -- BIRTH CERTIFICATE IS
REAL.
>> WHAT ABOUT PRESIDENT OBAMA
RELEASES HIG GRADES AS AN -- HIS
GRADES AS AN OLIVE BRANCH TO
RELEASE HIS TAXES.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THAT?
>> NOT A FAIR DEAL.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE IT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO FIND THE
TRANSCRIPTS --
[OVERLAPPING SPEAKERS]
>> WHAT HAPPENED WITH MELANIA.
DID HE LOCK HER UP?
>> LOCK HER UP?
>> IS THAT A BODY DOUBLE.
NO.
NOT A BODY DOUBLE.
>> WOW.
THIS IS WHERE THE CONVERSATION